[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wann hat es das schon mal gegeben dass
eine amtierende Ministerpräsidentin
bereit ist ihr Amt aufzugeben und in
einer neuen Koalition nur noch die
junior-rolle einzunehmen obwohl sie die
Option hätte so weiterzumachen wie
bisher
Berlins noch Regierende Bürgermeisterin
Franziska Giffey hat mit diesem Vorstoß
auch ihre eigene Landespartei überrascht
den Parteivorstand hat sie aber
mehrheitlich auf ihrer Seite wie sich
jetzt am späteren Abend zeigte wo man
leskova berichtet
viereinhalb Stunden wurde hinter
verschlossenen Türen verhandelt es ging
um eine kuriose Entscheidung eine
Regierende Bürgermeisterin die für einen
Schritt wird der ihr das Amt kosten
würde vor wenigen Minuten dann das
Ergebnis die Berliner SPD-Führung macht
den Weg frei für Koalitionsverhandlungen
mit der CDU wir haben mit der CDU
festgestellt gefällt das ist sehr große
Schnittmengen gab und gibt und das ist
auch ein großes Entgegenkommen gab
seitens der CDU um die Themen die uns
wichtig sind die wir vorangebracht haben
die wir in die Gespräche eingebracht
haben auch im Sinne der SPD zu lösen
die CDU könnte also bald erneut jubeln
am Wahlabend war noch unklar ob
siegerkai Wegener nur Held für eine
Nacht bleibt denn trotz Verlusten
reichten die Stimmen auch für ein weiter
regieren von rot grün rot jetzt legen
sich die Genossen fest und die CDU kann
den Partner womöglich sogar wählen grüne
oder SPD
es waren wirklich sehr gute
Sondierungsgespräche mit beiden Parteien
es gab natürlich unterschiedliche
Differenzen und unterschiedliche
Knackpunkte bei beiden nichtsdestotrotz
gab es keine unüberbrückbaren Gegensätze
wie wir festgestellt haben rot grün rot
war für Franziska Giffey von Anfang an
keinen Traum Bündnis eher
Zweckgemeinschaft unterschiedliche
Positionen wurden gern öffentlich
ausgetragen etwa beim Umgang mit dem
Volksentscheid zur Enteignung von
wohnungskonzernen sinnbildlich auch die
Eröffnung der Polizeiwache am
kriminalitätsschwerpunkt Cottbusser Tor
drinnen die SPD in Senatorin draußen
unter den Protestierenden ein linken
Politiker die Grünen hatten eigentlich
auf eine Fortsetzung des bisherigen
Bündnisses gesetzt vom geplanten
spd-votum erfuhren sie zwar schon
gestern allerdings aus den Medien wir
halten es prinzipiell nicht so gut dass
man so viel über die Medien kommuniziert
das war ein Problem dieser Regierung das
Ansagen per Medien gemacht wurden das
von der Koalitionsvertrag über die
Medien abgewichen wurde das war ein Stil
der SPD dem wird schon seit paar Jahren
kennen wir hätten gerne darüber
gesprochen in Ruhe wie man das ändert
das scheint jetzt nicht mehr der Fall zu
sein unklar ist ob der eher links
tickende spd-landesverband einem groko
Votum überhaupt folgen wird die
Parteimitglieder sollen am Ende
entscheiden für den Fall einer Einigung
wird bereits über Franziska Giffey als
super Senatorin mit großem Ressort
spekuliert eine Ministerpräsidentin die
freiwillig ins zweite Glied rückt es
wäre eine weitere Kuriosität nach der
Berlin Wahl
blauer Himmel und Sonnenschein passten
heute ja bestens zum meteorologischen
Frühlingsanfang der Winter ist im
Wesentlichen überstanden jener Winter
für den Wladimir Putin uns die reinste
Verdammnis vorhergesagt hatte auch viele
deutsche Politiker hatten vor diesem
Winter Angst gehabt Massenverarmung
industrielle Kernschmelze dunkle Städte
zeitweise schien ja alles denkbar so ist
es nicht gekommen die Gasspeicher sind
gut gefüllt die gaspreisbremse die heute
in Kraft tritt entlastet ja auch
rückwirkend für Januar und Februar das
heißt natürlich nicht dass mit den
Preissprüngen keine Härten einhergehen
oder dass die gaspreisbremse
unumstritten ist zumal jetzt wo die
Gaspreise an den Märkten sinken ist sie
überhaupt noch sinnvoll der Frage ist
Peter Böhmer nachgegangen
jede Menge Meetings bei Stadtwerken wie
in Krefeld hier sozusagen an der
Energiebasis müssen Sie die hektischen
politischen Entscheidungen letztlich aus
Baden und in Preise umsetzen wie bei der
gaspreisbremse 180 Seiten sperriger
Gesetzestext eigentlich müssten die
Kunden bis heute Post bekommen haben
Bescheid wissen über künftige Abschläge
energiekontingente Rabatte 10000 Briefe
die Hälfte haben sie nur geschafft das
Vorhaben war sicherlich etwas zu
ambitioniert zumindest für den Termin
der Hintergrund ist ganz einfach dass
wir abhängig sind von z.B
Software-Lieferanten Lieferanten unsere
Abrechnungssysteme die müssen erst
einmal Vorarbeit leisten weil der
Gaspreis Bremse Zahlen private Haushalte
maximal 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde Gas
bei Fernwärme 9,5 Cent allerdings nur
für ein bestimmtes Kontingent nämlich
80% des vorjahresverbrauchs wer mehr
verbraucht muss den Marktpreis seines
Versorgers zahlen das ganze wird
gerechnet zum ersten Januar
in den meisten Fällen wird es also
Rabatte geben eben darüber müssen die
Versorger bis heute informieren
allerdings gehen die Preise wieder
spürbar runter neu Kunden zahlen derzeit
sogar deutlich unter 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde
die Gründe der milde Winter
Einsparmaßnahmen neue importpartner war
die Preisbremse also überflüssig
na die gaspreisbremse war schon wichtig
vor allen Dingen auch psychologischer
Natur ein bisschen den Druck aus dem
Markt zu nehmen sie hat Sicherheit
gegeben aktuell sehen wir dass der Markt
die Preise deutlich besser senken kann
als der Staat fraglich ob und wie die
Preissenkungen weitergehen was früher
billig aus Russland camos heute teurer
eingekauft werden ich komme nicht wieder
auf das alte Gaspreisniveau zurück wir
werden Gas dauerhaft über Schiffe nach
Europa transportieren müssen und das ist
weil die Transportkosten so hoch sind
einfach viel teurer als das was wir
bisher hatten das heißt wir müssen uns
mit dauerhaft hören Gaspreisen und auch
Strompreisen irgendwie arrangieren aber
es wird nicht mehr diese Ausschläge
geben wie sie im letzten Jahr waren auch
bei der gaspreisbremse könnten Abzocker
zum zugekommen denn die Marktpreise für
Bestandskunden liegen ja oberhalb des 12
Cent Deckels auch im 80% Kontingent die
Differenz holt sich der Lieferant vom
Staat aus dem doppelbums Paket der
Bundesregierung schwarze Branchen Schafe
könnten ihre Preise einfach noch weiter
erhöhen der Steuerzahler müsste auch das
zahlen und genauso passiert ist
teilweise wohl auch
wir haben zu Jahresbeginn eine Welle vom
Preiserhöhungen bei vielen Anbietern
gesehen wir haben deutliche Erhöhungen
von Abschlagszahlungen beispielsweise
gesehen wir haben auch gesehen dass eben
der Verbrauch deutlich zu hoch angesetzt
worden ist der da abgerechnet worden ist
bei verbraucherverbraucherinnen aber
immerhin eine Beruhigung im
Energiesektor ist spürbar nach einer
Marktentwicklung die sie auch in Krefeld
noch nie erlebt haben
es ist geradezu schmerzhaft sich die
Fotos von damals anzusehen Merkel
Schröder der damalige russische
marionettenpräsident mit Mädchens der
inzwischen laufend besonders wüste
Drohungen gegen Deutschland ausstößt
damals war er noch der nette Herr mit
Mädchen mit dem man 2011 die erste
nordstream Pipeline eröffnet hatte keine
zweieinhalb Jahre später über viel Putin
erstmals die Ukraine holte sich die Krim
und den dornbas was Deutschland
bekanntlich nicht davon abhielt 2015 das
Projekt Nord Stream 2 zu beschließen
wie sich Deutschland trotz Warnungen so
an Russland hängen konnte und mit
welchen Methoden Moskau Einfluss nehmen
konnte dazu wird noch einiges
aufzuklären sein mit denen in dieser
Hinsicht besonderen Kapriolen in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern beschäftigte sich
heute der Bundestag
Finanzamt Ribnitz-Damgarten Frühjahr
letzten Jahres Aufregung in der Behörde
eine Steuererklärung ist verschwunden
eine junge Beamtin entdeckt sie
schließlich irgendwo in ihren Unterlagen
hatte sie offenbar verlegt und damit
keiner diesen Fehler bemerkt verbrennt
sie die Akte es war die Steuererklärung
der Stiftung für Klima und Umweltschutz
die politisch zwar längst tot ist die
ist aber immer noch gibt denn solange
eine Frage nicht entschieden ist
verweigert der Vorstand die Auflösung
ist die Stiftung gemeinnützig und damit
befreit von der Steuer oder nicht klar
ist ihr Hauptzweck war die Vollendung
von Nordstemmen 2 keine gemeinnützige
Aufgabe das sieht die Stiftung
allerdings ganz anders hat einen Antrag
auf Steuerbefreiung beim Finanzamt
eingereicht zusammen mit der
Steuererklärung die letztes Jahr
verbrannte Finanzminister Geue in
Erklärungsnot immerhin finanzieller
Schaden entstand nicht natürlich ist ein
Schaden für die im Steuerverwaltung
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern dadurch
entstanden wir stehen nicht gut da im
Moment die jüngste kuriose Kapriole in
der Schweriner daueraffäre landet heute
im Bundestag aktuelle Stunde beantragt
von der CDU Stoßrichtung Frontalangriff
auf die ministerpräsidente die CDU hat
regiert mit Manuela Schwesig als die
Klima Stiftung aufgesetzt wurde das
alles ist aber kein Blanco Scheck für
Kamin Geld das geht auf das Konto von
Manuela Schwesig
WLAN Angela Merkel noch Olaf Scholz noch
Peter Altmaier haben damals gesagt
Stiftung mit uns nicht nein die haben
das alles mitgetragen sie wollten das
Angela Merkel war in Wahrheit die Mutter
von Nordstemmen 2 und ich sage ganz klar
ich war auch für nord2 in Schwerin steht
der weil ein weiterer Vorwurf im Raum
auf die Entscheidung des Finanzamtes von
der Klimastiftung 9,8 Millionen Euro
Steuern zu fördern habe der
Finanzminister Einfluss genommen der
dementiert auch für die Opposition im
Land geht es nicht nur um die
Verantwortung des Ministers sondern um
die der Ministerpräsidentin Frau
Schwesig wird sich ganz klar
positionieren müssen wann sie in welcher
Entscheidung eingebunden war ich glaube
nicht dass solche Vorgänge dieses
Ausmaßes auch dieser Berichterstattung
von ihr ferngehalten wurden ich kenne
sie anders dass sie sich sehr sehr gut
informieren lässt mit der Staatskanzlei
oder Frau Schwesig ist darüber nicht
geredet worden das hat eine politische
Verantwortung der Regierungschefin sehen
Sie nicht sondern ihre ja natürlich am
Ende bin ich als Minister verantwortlich
aber noch mal für den Bescheid ist das
Finanzamt verantwortlich da gehört auch
hin gegen den Steuerbescheid hat die
Stiftung übrigens klar geeinigt Ausgang
offen aus der Staatskanzlei heute keine
Stellungnahme sicher ist der
Untersuchungsausschuss im Schweriner
Landtag hat Zeit dieser Woche noch ein
paar Punkte mehr auf seiner To-Do-Liste
auch wenn es nur ein geringer Trost ist
mit der Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas
war Deutschland nicht allein einige
andere EU-Länder beziehen bis heute viel
Gas aus Russland Deutschland tut das
inzwischen nicht mehr aber russisches Öl
das landet immer noch in unseren
Zapfsäulen nicht direkt sondern über
Indien das hier quasi als
Zwischenhändler fungiert
Indien hält sich ja eh raus aus diesem
Krieg und sieht keinen Anlass sich an
den Sanktionen gegen Russland zu
beteiligen
morgen treffen sich in Neu-Delhi die
Außenminister der G20-Staaten Norman
Odenthal wird das für uns beobachten
sie kommen von allen Seiten laut
rechthaberisch rücksichtslos
forderndis Verkehr ist wie ein
Spiegelbild der Weltpolitik Ordnung
reinzubringen scheint ein etwas
abenteuerliches Ziel zu sein auf den
Straßen der indischen Hauptstadt gilt
das ebenso wie auf der diplomatischen
Bühne die Erwartungen sind gemischt
wir haben den Vorsitz der G20-Staaten
wir können uns also als Führungsmacht
beweisen und für Verständigung Sorgen
das ist gut
es ist richtig wenn Indien neutral
bleibt sie erzählen uns zwar immer
Indien könne den Krieg in der Ukraine
beenden aber das ist einfach Unsinn
der Russe lavrov kommt als einer der
ersten seine Schlüsselrolle liegt auf
der Hand lässt sich Russland zu
irgendetwas bewegen ausgerechnet hier in
Indien das von guten Beziehungen zu
Moskau profitiert von Sanktionen will
Delhi nichts wissen im Gegenteil das
Energiegeschäft brummt mehr denn je
Indien ist gerade sehr aktiv dabei
russisches Rohöl zu importieren und zwar
zu sehr günstigen Preisen und das dann
in den heimischen Raffinerien zu Diesel
zu verarbeiten und das dann auch nach
Europa und nach Deutschland zu verkaufen
wir kriegen also so gesehen weiterhin
russisches Öl nur eben jetzt verpackt in
indischen Diesel ein Boykott mit ganz
bewusst gewordenen Löchern aber wie
wirksam sind Sanktionen die man verhängt
und selbst umgeht warum macht
Deutschland damit kommt erst das Tanken
dann die Moral wir haben dadurch
einerseits die Versorgung einen
deutschen Tankstellen gesichert
andererseits und das ist das die gute
Nachricht haben wir schon dafür gesorgt
dass Wladimir Putin deutlich weniger Öl
Einnahmen hat im russischen
Staatshaushalt mit dem man den Krieg
finanziert also so gesehen hat dieser
Mittelweg zwei Ziele erreicht und das
ist erstmal eine gute Nachricht
es ist also nicht nur Indien das
Interesse am billigen Ölimport hat so
wird dann auch klar warum kaum Kritik an
Delis Geschäften mit Moskau laut wird
das ist für Europa schon eine knifflige
Sache wenn russisches Öl auf diesem
verdeckten Umweg nach Europa kommt über
Indien das erklärt warum nicht mit dem
Finger auf Indien gezeigt wird denn dann
müsste Europa mit dem Finger auch auf
sich selbst zeigen
im Geflecht all dieser Interessen sollen
die G20 Staaten einen Weg finden den
möglichst viele mitgehen als Gastgeber
und Vermittler kommt also mächtig was
auf Indien zu einen Vorgeschmack liefert
der Russe lawrov schon am Abend gewohnt
krawalligi sind sich einig einseitige
Sanktionen nach Kolonialherren Art
Drohungen Erpressung Druck auf souveräne
Staaten das ist alles unakzeptabel
Russland das Opfer mal wieder wenn das
den Ton für morgen setzt dann wird es
schwer hier was zu bewegen Weltpolitik
scheint gerade komplizierter denn je
ja Weltpolitik in Zeiten eines
Angriffskrieges in Europa damit geht es
jetzt auch bei dir weiter Heinz Finnland
hat den nächsten Schritt Richtung NATO
gemacht das Parlament stimmte mit
breiter Mehrheit für das Gesetz zum
NATO-Beitritt nach dem Beschluss durch
das Parlament muss das Gesetz nun nur
noch vom Präsidenten abgesegnet werden
was als sicher gilt aber für den
Beitritt zur NATO fehlt dann weiterhin
noch die Ratifizierung durch die Türkei
und auch durch Ungarn
der belarussische macht aber Lukaschenko
ein enger Verbündeter von chemisches
putin war heute in Peking zu Gesprächen
mit der chinesischen Führung China
Staatschef hier und Lukaschenko betonten
die Zusammenarbeit und die Freundschaft
ihrer Länder sie sprachen auch über
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Lukaschenko stellte sich nach Angaben
des chinesischen Staatsfernsehens hinter
das jüngst vorgelegte Positionspapier
Pekings das beide Seiten zu
Verhandlungen auffordert
nach dem schweren Zugunglück in
Griechenland in der vergangenen Nacht
ist weiter unklar wie es dazu kommen
konnte
griechenlandsministerpräsident mich
total gesprochen am Abend allerdings von
Hinweisen auf menschliches Fehlverhalten
43 Tote wurden bislang aus den
Verunglückten Zügen geborgen mehr als 80
Menschen wurden verletzt ein Personen
und ein Güterzug waren auf der Strecke
zwischen Athen und Thessaloniki kurz vor
Mitternacht bei der Stadt Larissa
frontal zusammengestoßen und entgleist
einige Waggons fingen Feuer die Züge
waren auf der zweigleisigen Strecke auf
demselben Gleis gefahren
nachdem die Bundesregierung zwei
Angehörige der iranischen Botschaft
ausgewiesen hat weist nun Iran zwei
deutsche Diplomaten aus das Auswärtige
Amt nannte die Entscheidung hier heranz
erwartbar aber ungerechtfertigt die
Bundesregierung hatte vergangene Woche
die beiden iranischen
Botschaftsangehörigen ausgewiesen als
Reaktion auf das Todesurteil gegen einen
Deutsch Iraner
auch wenn die deutsche Wirtschaft
derzeit schwächelt der Arbeitsmarkt
bleibt weitgehend stabil das zeigen die
neuen Zahlen der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit demnach erhöhte sich im Februar
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen leicht auf 2
Millionen 620.000 4.000 mehr als im
Januar im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind
192.000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos die
Arbeitslosenquote bleibt unverändert bei
5,7%
. der Begriff feministische Außenpolitik
den sich Anna-Lena baerbock auf die
Fahne schreibt hat ja einigen Spott auf
sich gezogen und den Vorwurf
Außenpolitik damit ideologisch oder
moralisch zu überfrachten dem halten
Befürworter entgegen dass Frauen Themen
keineswegs nur etwas mit Moral zu tun
haben sondern sehr reale Wirtschaft oder
sicherheitspolitische Dimensionen haben
so ist zum Beispiel nicht jedem bewusst
dass die Vergewaltigung von Frauen nicht
etwas ist was in Kriegsgebieten leider
Gottes passiert sondern dass das eine
Kriegswaffe ist die systematisch
eingesetzt wird zur Demoralisierung des
Gegners
solche Themen stärker in den Vordergrund
zu rücken soll Teil dieser neuen
außenpolitischen Leitlinien sein was da
heute vorgestellt wurde und welche
Kritik ist daran gibt berichtet
Henriette de Maiziere
zwei sichtlich zufriedene Ministerin
präsentieren heute in Berlin ihre Pläne
sie rufen keine Revolution aus sagt
Außenministerin bärbock sondern fordern
das Selbstverständliche da auf der Welt
die Hälfte einer Gesellschaft aus Frauen
besteht müssen auch ihre ganz normalen
Probleme und Herausforderungen
berücksichtigt werden und deswegen ist
unsere feministische Außenpolitik ein
real-feminismus der deutlich macht dass
man sich mit den realen
Herausforderungen vor Ort
auseinandersetzen muss immer wieder
trifft bärbock auf ihren Reisen
VertreterInnen von Frauenorganisationen
nimmt die Probleme der Frauen in den
Blick nach innen musste sie ihre Politik
bisher oft verteidigen mir Bericht ist
das Herz weil ich bei den Müttern von
Screen Benutzer war vor einer Woche und
die mir beschrieben haben wie die Spuren
dieses Krieges in ihnen drin sind und
deswegen gehört zu einer
sicherkeitspolitik des 21 jahrhundert
auch eine feministische Sichtweise das
ist kein Gedöns Frauen sollen künftig
die gleichen Rechte haben den gleichen
Anspruch auf Ressourcen die gleiche
Entscheidungsmacht bekommen von ihrem
Sport für feministische Außenpolitik hat
sich die Opposition inzwischen entfernt
wichtig ist aber dass die feministische
Außenpolitik wirklich einen Unterschied
macht dass sie konkret wird und dass sie
dann auch messbare Ergebnisse zeigt wie
feministische Außenpolitik aussehen kann
zeigt das Beispiel Madagaskar eines der
ärmsten Länder der Welt Frauen leisten
hier einen Hauptteil der Arbeit auf den
Feldern dürfen aber kaum mitbestimmen
dank eines Hilfsprojekts können Sie nun
Land erwerben lernen wie man richtig
wirtschaftet bekommen mehr Rechte die
Leitlinien sollen außen und
Entwicklungspolitik konsequent zusammen
denken wir wollen mithelfen mit unserer
Entwicklungspolitik den Hunger in der
Welt zu bekämpfen Armut zu bekämpfen wir
wollen Gesellschaften gerechter machen
und da kann man nicht auf die Hälfte des
Potenzials nämlich auf die Frauen
verzichten das Kabinett hat heute die
Leitlinien verabschiedet sie sollen
helfen einen feministischen Reflex
auszubilden sich durch alle Bereiche
ziehen Krisen Diplomatie humanitäre
Hilfe Kulturpolitik und
Friedensverhandlungen es gibt
Untersuchungen die zeigen dass wenn
Frauen bei Friedensverhandlungen mit am
Tisch sitzen mit verhandeln dass der
Frieden viel nachhaltiger ist und viel
länger hält und das ergibt natürlich
auch total Sinn denn
politische Entscheidungen sind natürlich
immer nur so gut wie die Köpfe dahinter
einbezogen werden die feministische
Außenpolitik sie sollen nicht nur nach
außen wirken auch das Ministerium selbst
so die Ankündigung bearbox soll
weiblicher und diverser werden da sei
noch viel Luft nach oben
wie schwierig ist dann aber in der
Praxis ist entsprechend außenpolitisch
Einfluss zu nehmen zeigt sich beim Blick
auf die systematische Unterdrückung der
Frauen ist dort auch macht Instrument
eines korrupten autoritären Systems und
der Kampf für Frauenrechte zu einem
Freiheitskampf geworden der die Männer
genauso angeht und von Männern
mitgetragen wird auch sie skandieren
Frau Leben Freiheit
wie brutal ist dabei zugeht zeigt sich
nicht nur an den vielen Hinrichtungen
neuerdings werden Schulmädchen vergiftet
Diana zimmermann
ein Mädchen lehnt an einer Schulmauer
und schreit ich kann nicht atmen mehrere
andere Ringen um Luft Eltern und Kinder
in heller Aufregung heute allein wurden
solche Vorkommnisse aus vier Schulen in
Teheran gemeldet schon nach offiziellen
Zahlen waren in den vergangenen drei
Monaten 58 Schulen in 10 Provinzen
betroffen 900 Mädchen zeigten
Vergiftungserscheinungen doch jetzt erst
äußerte sich der Innenminister der
Islamischen Republik
der Geheimdienst wird herausfinden
welche Gruppen das getan haben ob es
vielleicht aus Abenteuerlust geschah sie
werden es dann mitteilen aber noch
wissen wir es nicht
das externe gruppenmädchen Schulen im
ganzen Land angreifen und ausgerechnet
der müller-staat mit seiner hohen Dichte
an Spitzeln nicht weiß wer die Attacken
verübt bezweifeln viele auch in der
diasbauer die Exil iranische Aktivistin
Marcia in New York wurde in den letzten
Tagen von Anrufen aus dem Iran nur so
überschwemmt
ich habe mit einem Vater gesprochen der
auch Arzt ist und mir sagte dass allein
in der Schule seiner Tochter die Hälfte
der SchülerInnen ins Krankenhaus
eingeliefert worden sei viele haben
Angst die Rettungswagen zu benutzen weil
sie glauben dass die Islamische Republik
hinter diesen chemischen Angriffen steht
Krankenhausabteilungen fühlen sich mit
den Opfern und natürlich sorgen sich
nicht nur die Eltern bereits Betroffener
Mädchen sondern alle
meine Tochter traut sich nicht mehr in
die Schule und die Regierung hat nichts
getan
ich lerne jetzt lieber zu Hause
die Regierung und andere tun viele Dinge
damit die Leute beschäftigt sind und
damit die Regierung weiter tun kann was
sie will
das sind Leute die nicht wollen dass die
Mädchen ihren Status in der Gesellschaft
verbessern
so manche vermutet gar gezielte Rache
des Regimes
die Leute mit denen ich spreche schreien
Tod traminei vor den Schultoren sie
sagen mir es ist die Islamische Republik
die hinter den Attacken steckt denn sie
hat Angst vor mutigen Mädchen die den
Job abnehmen die den Hauptpfeiler eines
Regimes der Gender Apartheid erschüttern
und die den Massenprotest angeführt
haben
eine mutige Mutter protestiert laut und
wird an den Haaren Weg gezerrt wer auch
immer hinter den Attacken steckt könnte
sich verrechnet haben Angst und Ohnmacht
sind die Quellen von Wut
zum Thema feministische Außenpolitik
gibt es nachher im heute journal Update
ein Interview mit der CDU-Politikerin
und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
Blick auf die Wirtschaft die
Verbraucherpreise sind auch im Februar
im Jahresvergleich wieder um 8,7%
gestiegen sagt der Statistische
Bundesamt nach seiner ersten Schätzung
das ist der gleiche Wert wie schon im
Januar Frank Bethmann wie stets also um
die Hoffnungen dass die Inflation bald
wieder mal zurückgeht ja die Hoffnung
ist da und sie wird vor allem genährt
von der Statistik der Krieg in der
Ukraine hatte vor Jahresfrist die Preise
sprunghaft steigen lassen und zwar von
Februar auf mehr als die dann folgenden
Monate so einen außerordentlichen
preisschopf gab es nun aber im Februar
2023 nicht noch ein zweites mal was ich
damit sagen will jetzt von März an
werden die monatlichen Preise mit denen
deutlich gestiegenen nach Beginn des
Krieges verglichen das dürfte die
Inflation rein technisch einbremsen aber
wohl nicht gänzlich stoppen aus einer
aktuellen Umfrage geht hervor dass
Lebensmittel Einzelhändler mehrheitlich
über weitere Preiserhöhungen in den
einen Monaten nachdenken Reisen und
Restaurantbesuche dürften sich laut der
Befragung ebenfalls weiter verteuern mit
der Entwicklung der Preise können die
Löhne nicht mithalten die Lohnerhöhungen
die es in den vergangenen Jahr gab
wurden durch die steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten mehr als
aufgefressen die Reallöhne sind 2022 das
dritte Jahr in Folge gesunken im letzten
Jahr um 3,1 Prozent laut Statistischen
Bundesamt Wasser auf die Mühlen der
Gewerkschaften die aktuellen zahlreichen
Branchen sie bekommen das alles mit für
einen kräftigeren Schluck aus der Pole
kämpfen Frank Wittmann vielen Dank
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr acht 14 21 23 28 47 Superzahl 9
und weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
Wettbewerb in der Kombination hat
Norwegen gewonnen Silber ging an die
deutsche Mannschaft aus Eric Frenzel
Vinzenz Geige Johannes und Julian
Schmidt und beim Skispringen wir waren
Katharina Althaus heute von der
Großschanze Bronze siegerin wurde
Alexandra Ludwig aus Kanada vor der
Norwegen
als klar war dass Sie mindestens die
bonsmedaille sicher haben würde entblut
sich bei Katharina Althaus die enormer
Anspannung in ausgelassener Freude mit
Sprüngen auf 120,5 und 128 Meter lag sie
vor den beiden letzten Konkurrentinnen
zunächst noch an der Spitze doch sowohl
Titelverteidigerin Maren Olympia aus
Norwegen als auch die Kanadierin
Alexandria Ludwig übertrafen die Weite
der Oberstdorferin und überließen
Althaus diesmal die Bons Medaille
von der WM mit vier Medaillen Heimfahrt
dreimal Gold einmal Bronze unglaublich
einfach und das feiere ich jetzt mal so
richtig was für eine fantastische WM für
Katharina Althaus die sich neben der
neuen Weltmeisterin der 19-Jährigen
Kanadierin Alexandria Ludwig und der
Norwegerin marily über ihre vierte
WM-Medaille aus vollem Herzen und aus
voller Kehle freuen konnte
[Applaus]
das war von uns gleich geht's im Ausland
schon mal weiter unter anderem mit einem
Bericht aus den Erdbebengebieten in der
Türkei wie wirken sich Verzweiflung und
Wut der Menschen auch auf die politische
Stimmung im Lande aus und um 0:30 Uhr
gibt's dann unsere heute schnell Update
bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter Trockenheit bleibt
weiterhin ein Thema wir haben hier
unsere regensum-karte also der Regen der
dazu kommt färbt die Karte blau vor
allem sehen wir das hier über dem
Mittelmeer hier ist ein Tief aktiv und
das bringt noch mal bis zu 80 Liter auf
den Quadratmeter zum Wochenende gibt's
auch etwas Regen und Schnee in
Deutschland das ist aber nicht viel ein
bis zehn Liter kommen da zusammen ja und
ziemlich trocken bleibt es weiterhin in
Frankreich da regnet es fast gar nicht
schauen wenn die kommende nachts nach
Norden hin bildet sich Hochnebel hier
und da ist es auch aufgelockert vor
allem aber in der Mitte und auch im
Süden da wird es neblig werden und das
bei tiefsten Temperaturen von -9 Grad
nach Osten hin und zwei Grad an der
Nordsee aber häufig liegen die
Temperaturen unter der Null Grad Marke
morgen dann Lücken in der Hochnebel
Artikel im Norden teilweise löst er sich
auf im Süden auch etwas freundlicher
wenn der Nebel sich auflöst hat zwischen
aber viel Sonnenschein und weiterhin
teils Bürger Ostwind bei höchsten
Temperaturen von bis zu 13 Grad im
Südosten 12 Grad Richtung Rhein-Main
hier in diesem Streifen wird es am
mildesten ansonsten aber unter dem Nebel
nach Norden hin zum Beispiel nur vier
Grad ja die nächsten Tage am Freitag
bleibt es trocken teils noch mit
sonnigen Abschnitten bei drei bis zehn
Grad und am Wochenende kommt etwas Regen
und auch Schnee dazu aber wir haben es
auf der Karte gesehen viel wird es nicht
sein damit ein schöner Abend